ja und einer der heute auch im bundestag
sein wird ist der cdu
bundestagsabgeordnete
philipp am tor der uns jetzt
zugeschaltet des guten morgen abend ort
schönen guten morgen habe es im
deutschen bundestag herrn tur heute
mittag übertragen wir bei bild live hier
die erste fragestunde im bundestag mit
bundeskanzler olaf scholz wo werden wir
sie dann sehen auf der tribüne oder im
plenarsaal unten ich werde im plenarsaal
sein aber ich will vorausschicken es ist
schon wichtig dass wir in dieser
aktuellen situation sehen der deutsche
bundestag ist eben keine insel man ist
nicht alles gekoppelt von dem
infektionsgeschehen in dem land das wir
im moment sehen in deutschland und
deswegen ist es auch notwendig dass wir
jetzt hier über dieses neue hygiene
konzentrieren und wenn sie die
fragestunde ansprechen dann glaube ich
ist es doch entscheiden welche argumente
in den fragen kommen wie klug die fragen
sind die gestellt werden das steht doch
vielleicht mehr im vordergrund als die
frage ob man sie von der tribüne aus
infektionsschutz gründen oder irgendwo
aus dem saal
ich würde es anders sehen ungeimpfte
abgeordnete werden auf der tribüne zur
schau gestellt wie würden sie sich dafür
ich sehe das nicht so sondern es geht
darum dass wir ein hygiene konzept auf
den weg bringen mussten dass insgesamt
die durchführung der parlamentssitzung
im aktuellen infektionsgeschehen
ermöglicht ich meine wir müssen uns vor
augen führen dass wir durch die
beschlüsse der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz jetzt zweig
plus fast flächendeckend im ganzen land
haben wir haben nach wie vor kontakt
beschränkungen auf zehn personen und da
mutet es doch dann schon zumindest
rechtfertigungsbedarf dich an wie man
ein parlamentsbetrieb mit 700
abgeordneten durchführen will und da
halte ich es für geradezu falsch wenn
wir nicht im bundestag auch gleichmäßig
über die hygiene konzepte die wir für
die gesamtbevölkerung einführen damit
darüber nicht reden würden und deswegen
ist es so dass dieses regelungskonzept
jetzt im zuge auch die
selbstorganisation der abgeordneten
gefunden wurde ich bin davon überzeugt
dass es verfassungsrechtlich zu
rechtfertigen ist wie man jetzt trennt
wir wollen mal hören was das volk über
das saal verbot für ungeimpfte
volksvertreter denkt wir haben uns in
esslingen in baden württemberg berg
einmal umgehört
von der künftigen zweig plus regel im
bundestag da halte ich jetzt nicht so
viel ich find's nicht gut finde die
einschränkung von der freiheit dafür
jeder selber entscheiden was gemacht und
mächtige also ich finde es so lange das
noch keine pflicht ist dass sich jeder
impfen muss schon eine art
zweiklassengesellschaft ich bin gegen
die wege weil
sie sollten sich
impfen ich bin folgt dagegen dass im
bundestag jemand sprechen kann der
umgehend ist und kämpfte politiker
sollten meiner meinung nach zu hause
bleiben sollten sich alle politiker sich
impfen im bundestag und genese und nicht
kämpfte können sollten sich auch
zusammenhocken
finde das so meiner meinung nach bist du
so diskriminierend trotzdem dass auch
die nicht geimpften gleiche rechte haben
sollten wie die geposteten
also gespaltene meinungen herunter und
genau ist das genau das ist ja das
problem
bundestagsabgeordnete sind also auch
volksvertreter und also damit auch
vertreter von ungeimpften bürgern die
vollen sich ohnehin ausgeschlossen aus
der gesellschaft spaltet das nicht noch
mal weiter ich kann zumindest sagen ist
diese bestandsaufnahme die sieger aus
esslingen zeigen so auch ein bild trifft
das in vielen anderen stellen unseres
landes genauso wagen um meinem wahlkreis
in mecklenburg vorpommern gibt es
natürlich eine sehr differenzierte sicht
und ich finde eines ganz wichtig diese
neue hygiene regelung die jetzt auf den
weg gebracht wurde doch nicht so
verstanden werden dass ungeimpfte
abgeordnete irgendwie ausgeschlossen
werden von der teilhabe an der
parlamentarischen diskussion
ich persönlich habe mich für die impfung
entschieden wie die allermeisten in
deutschland findet das auch gut und
richtig aber es kann natürlich nicht
sein dass der ungeliebte abgeordnete
jetzt ausgeschlossen wurde aus den
parlamentsbetrieb da gibt es klare auch
verfassungsrechtliche grenzen aber ich
glaube man kann schon erwarten so zu
sagen dass man sich dann in dieses
hygiene konzept einfügt am ende bin ich
aber jedenfalls überzeugt es zielt die
kraft der argumente und nicht von wo aus
im plenarsaal man sie adressiert und da
muss ich ihnen sagen von den fdp
abgeordneten die dort platz genommen
haben auf den tribünen daran nicht immer
unbedingt jetzt die klügsten
wortbeiträge zu hören mal sehen ob das
anders ist ich bin jedenfalls wenn man
argumente statt empörung an den tag
legen würde dann wäre der ganzen
parlamentarischen debatte jedenfalls
geholfen sagt cdu bundestagsabgeordneter
philipp amthor vielen dank für das
gespräch
dank beste grüße